So I'm talking today with Nina paling who's a brilliant animator and
She's making a variety of short films which I guess are going to be joined together into a longer film
about that that feature Old Testament themes and she's the creator of the animated musical feature Sita sings the blues'
her adventures in our broken copyright system
led her to join questioned copyright or guest artist in residence in
2008 where she produced a series of animated shorts above intellectual freedom called minute memes
More recently she made this land is mine, which is absolutely brilliant
shocking
devastating
and also aesthetically impressive film
About Israel Palestine and Canaan the Levant and that's intended for her new feature film
Seder masochism and you can find a lot of Nina's
pieces of pieces of that film online and I would highly recommend
Watching them. We'll
Cut a couple of them into this interview so that you can see what she's up to
So I guess there's two things that we could really talk about
I think the most important one obviously is your work, but I guess the second one is your
Concern for intellectual freedom and your your feeling with regards to two copyrights
Copying is not that
Stealing a thing leaves one less left copying. It makes one thing more. That's what copies for
Copying is not set
Goodbye, copied yours who have it blue one for me and one for you. That's what copies can do
To take
I just copy it. There's one for each of us. We're making more up a thing
That is what we call copying sharing ideas with everyone. That's why copying is
But let's let's start let's start by talking about you first
Tell tell my listeners and tell me who you are and where you come from and and what you're about
You want to know about my identity I guess yeah, trust me to identify
Myself, I don't trust myself there. Well, okay. You're the best source we have today
actually, I'm
Not sure about that
I mean, I think most of us would agree that I'm an artist and
Currently an animator. I guess I've been doing animation since 1998
Before that I was a newspaper cartoonist. I still do comics from time to time not very often. I
Mean, I guess the thing is I've just been I just came back from a bike ride
And I've just been thinking about identity like all the time and how incredibly unreliable it is and how I don't respect it
including ways that I identify myself
Well, I guess that's part of being an artist, you know, because people who are artistic or high in trade openness
And that gives them a very fluid identity us
I mean, it's an advantage because people who are high in openness can think laterally and they're always coming coming up with creative ideas
But it does tend to make their identity rather pluralistic and and and sometimes unstable and that can also be a problem
Well, I guess I guess it's not even that it's fluid
It's not like oh, I don't identify this way one day in this way another day. It's just I don't really
Currently have much respect for the idea of identity at all
And I could you know, say all kinds of things about myself but you know, does that actually do me any good?
Well, let me ask you a couple of basic questions. Where do you live?
Good. I live in Urbana, Illinois. That's verifiable. All right, and where were you born?
I was born in Urbana, Illinois were so you've been there your whole life, essentially? No I left
I was twenty I moved to Santa Cruz California. I wanted to be a hippie I failed
But then, you know, I was already out on my own so I briefly moved to Austin Texas didn't work out
I moved to San Francisco in 1991. I lived there for 11 years in 2002. I followed my then-boyfriend
Actually, we were legally married. So my then-husband to India
which is the subject one of the subjects of Sita sings the blues' and
Then later in 2002
I moved to Brooklyn New York and lived in various places in New York for a total of about ten years
I moved back to her banner in 2012 right after my father died and
Here I am and so why did you move back to her van and after all that adventuring
First I was done with New York, even though I really loved New York, especially
You know my first five years there. I was fantastic. I kind of
achieved
more than I even expected I would be able to and
started to just get I don't know the love affair with New York kind of wore off and
I wanted a little more peace and quiet and I wanted cooler summers and I didn't want a small garbage everywhere all the time
I had an opportunity to move back here because my dad died. My mom was threatening to sell the house
I joined the Occupy movement
occupy mom's house
Trying to keep her from something the house, but so you actually have a specific demand
She sold the house anyway, but I'm living in her new house. Oh
yeah, I was I was dating somebody that lived here and
That has ended but I actually really like it. It's much more relaxed and
Inexpensive, I get lots of fresh air. I take lots of bike rides and I don't really care about
the
I'm just less stressed out
Yeah, good any less? Yes
Well, you have plenty of adventures obviously
so I guess and it must take a fair bit of I would think time of quiet and and
Some isolation in order to work on your animation
Yeah, well, I achieved that quite an isolation in New York actually by just living in New York and in a by myself
I would rather live in New York than visit New York because when you live there you can actually control
Your environment somewhat and you can shut everything out. Whereas when you're visiting usually have to be out all the time being overstimulated, right?
Yes, well, it's definitely an over stimulating place
Yeah, when did you start doing your animation? I?
Started animating as an adult in 1998 before that
I had done some animation when I was 13 years old using a borrowed super 8 camera and
I just completely stopped because I was in central Illinois and there was no
support for
Doing animation. There was no way I could have advanced beyond the neighbors super 8 camera
But then in 1998, I was burning out of my daily comic strip and
Wanted to do something and borrowed somebody else's super 8 camera and in 1998, it actually was easier
To advance, especially in San Francisco where a lot of people were doing independent film
And yeah, I just stick up where I left off. I did, you know plasticine clay
stuff on super 8 and
shared that film with a band called Nick Phelps and the sprocket ensemble that did live music to animation and
That was really fun. I was being gratified by audience feedback
and so I made another film on 16 millimeter and then my next film was drawing and scratching on 35 millimeter and then
My next film after that was drawing and scratching on
IMAX film which is 70 millimeter really big frames and then I got into flash
Macromedia flash and I've been digital ever since and
Are you using Macromedia flash now?
What's your primary technology a lot of those clips for sadomasochism or animated in Macromedia Flash?
Adobe bought flash and crippled it and ruined it in the opinion of many Flash animators
So I'm still using Macromedia flash from 1990, you know
2007 it's that one my copy of Flash's from iron Macromedia flash 8, it only runs on older computers actually
I think it might be 2006 or 2005 so I have this old
Mac here
running OS 10 point 6 because it won't run on any more recent machines and
You know, it's like impossible to integrate with a
modern video editing system, so I have a new Mac as well and
The newer parts those sadomasochism. I'm using a program called Moho Pro
12 which is
Kept up with runs on modern computers
Yeah, it's funny how sometimes software Peaks in terms of complexity and usability and then goes downhill
You know, I think we're seeing that not just with software but with computers altogether like personal computers, I think peaked
around 2007 maybe 2010 and they've been getting worse ever since like any sort of upgrade to operating systems just means
More surveillance and less user freedom at this point
Yes, as well as a steep learning curve
Yeah
Yeah, anyway, I don't know I don't know if I can keep animating digitally
Because you know like the software that I'm using now Moho I just found out that the person that created it and was an integral
part of its team this whole time just left the company so
You know, mohos fate is unclear and I'm like if I have to learn a whole other piece of software again
I just don't know if I can take this anymore
I mean, I'm so fluent with flash it took me years to become fluent at all. Whoa-ho
well, that's another thing is that I know it takes a long time to become an expert user of a complex software program and then
when it shifts the ground shifts from underneath you it's rather disheartening because all of that expertise is
Essentially disappears and I guess it's part of what we're experiencing as our technology advances
Fast enough so that our lifespans are too long really to keep up. You know, we get we get
outdated and
Superannuated on about a five-year rotation and the dust get exhausting. Yeah. Well, maybe I'll just die early and won't have to worry about
But then you won't film finish your film and that seems like a bad idea
Well, I'm gonna finish this film. I finally see the light at the end of the tunnel for sadomasochism good for you
So let me ask you some about that. So now you made this land is mine. When was that that
Was 2012 I think it was that's the first scene that I made
This love is mine
God gave this line to me
This ray
a nation line
To me
Reveals inflamed
Then I see where children can run free
This one and whoa
I will
Just a mile when you are my son
I know I can like these
Oh just uh
With the house
To make this land
So it's gonna be the last scene in the film
But it's the first one that I made I see and what what possessed you to make that?
so I knew I wanted to make a movie about Passover because I was raised observing Passover, although not much else and
So I was doing research I had never seen the movie Exodus you know that movie
Yeah, I'd never seen it. So I watched it as part of my research and I learned that the theme music
Had lyrics written to it by Pat Boone and that it was a really popular song in the 60s
Tons of artists did it I had never even heard it before
So I heard it and I just thought it was ridiculous, right this land is mine. God gave this land to me
I mean any everyone would say that right? Everybody every group feels that way about the land that they're on every single one
so the absurdity of it was just a parent in the song and
You know
There wasn't even really a process of of coming up with a concept for it
It was just that was what the song evoked for me
It was just showing how every single person or not every single person that every single
tribe
Has that attitude towards their land and so saying that this land is yours and God gave this land to me
gives you no authority at all because
That's every I mean, that's just what it is to be a tribe living on land
So what should what sort of reaction did you garner from? This land is mine
This land is mine is the most popular thing I have ever made. It's been viewed on various channels more than 10 million times
And
You know many people like it in terms of criticism. The criticism seems equally divided between
People that say that I'm a Zionist and people that say I'm an anti Zionist
So it's either a really anti Zionist film or it's a really Zionist film
I see so you can just add that criticism together in sum to zero and ignore it
Yeah, well, I'm really flattered by it. Right because of people that passionately, you know
Polar opposite sides are
Saying that then I feel like I've really done something right? Well, you've definitely done something, right?
I mean, I think that was the first film of yours that I saw and then I've watched many of them
I think every one I could get my hands on since then and
It struck me in a variety of ways. I mean the first thing that's let's say strange about your
Animation is that it's this?
At first of all you have great taste in music
The best
I don't
How's that how's that working out for you? Well, okay in the case of this land is mine
It's pretty clear-cut fair use because the Sun the film is parody
like I said, right, you know it it's literally a parody of those lyrics and you
Know that's various
Okay
I actually think most of my uses are fair use their transformative but a
lot of uses are not as clear-cut as
Parity, so that's actually a really interesting issue
With the film and how is this film going to be released?
And how is it going to be shown?
because there is no no way I am going to ask for permission to use this music particularly music that
Entered my head as a child
Which I did not consent to and I had no control over it or so
Nobody has any control over what goes into your head right like you go out in the world and music is playing it goes into
your head
And yet once it's there
that part of your head that it occupies belongs to a corporation and
I'm just done asking corporations for permission to
Use what's in my head which they put there. Mm-hmm. Okay, so you basically solve the problem by saying to hell with it
I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna do this no matter what and you're gonna iron out whatever difficulties there are with that as you move along
That's what it looks like. It's an illegal film. I mean in the case of Sita sings the blues' I
Made Sita sings the blues' when I was I was certainly questioning copyright
But I didn't really see it as a completely bankrupt institution
so
when that film was done, I
Cleared all the rights which was an incredibly difficult process and required hiring
Intermediaries because the rights holders don't talk to normal people. So if you do make a film and you don't have
Permission to use the music in it. You can't simply ask for permission
They won't talk to you. So you have to pay lawyers and intermediaries
Just for them to even listen to you to tell you how much money they're demanding which is inevitably an absurd amount that you can't
Afford but I ended up spending a mere seventy thousand dollars
To make Sita sings the blues' legal to show for free and legal to share for free
If I you know wanted some other model, it would have been more than that, right
seventy thousand dollars
To be able to give it away
But I'm not doing that with a new film the new film
I'm making an illegal film all of my music choices have to do not with their licenses but with
The content and meaning and resonance of the songs
Most songs have a kind of cultural resonance that is related to the point in time
they were
circulating
For example, this land is mine, you know refers directly to this period of the 60s
Yeah, it has a cultural resonance because of that which a new song if I like commissioned a new song
Sort of like that. It wouldn't have the same meaning at all. No, definitely not songs like that. They pick up
It's really interesting to watch what happens to a song across time because it picks up
It's embedded into context in that context grows and develops and transforms
This dassault a song is really a mutable entity. You know it transforms tremendously as it moves across time
Yeah, and that and that meaning comes from the audience it doesn't come from
Even the person that wrote it let alone the copyright holder right the value of it
Comes from us. Okay. So back to this land is mine
So when I watched that it produced a lot of mixed feelings. I mean the first was that
it was it's very black ly humorous and
You know you have this stirring
propagandistic
Anthem, like music in the background. It's it's sort of overblown
The singer, you know, he he he amplifies the emotional resonance of it. And then you have this just non-stop
carnage in the background to this to this stirring music and then
but what's really strange about it as far as I was concerned is that it's eerily beautiful and
Not something that's it seems to be a perverse and remarkable element of all of your films is that they deal with extremely harsh
Realities
metaphysical and and
Genuine, but you have this amazing capacity to generate these
complex beautiful images and to set them in a you know
and in an equally beautiful relationship to the music and so I mean I
Didn't know what and still don't know what to make of the film because you don't often see
What you might describe is stunningly beautiful satire stunningly beautiful artistic satire. I
Don't know Mad Magazine was pretty stunningly beautiful
Back back it had like the best artists working for it
Yeah, that's true. That's true. But your your there's an element to what you're doing
Especially with the juxtaposition of the music that seems to elevate it in my opinion to something like the level of high art
What high what slow well thank you, I thank you for the compliment. I can't really respond any with anything other than thanking you so
Your aesthetic sense and the style that you developed
Do you do you have sources for that? Do you have influences that helped you helped you?
Develop that particular style. I mean, I know it's a foolish question to ask to artists where they give their ideas
But I'm I'm wondering how it is that you came up with the concepts that you're working with
well
graphically
Some of the style is determined by the software that I use
so this land is mine and all the song scenes and sadomasochism are flash and
Flash the way I use it
It's what we call a cutout style where I'll draw shapes and I'll move them in relation to each other, but the shapes themselves
Don't bend or anything. They're just
cutout is an animation technique where people would literally cut out shapes from paper and
Move them around under a camera
So that's part of the style
With this land is mine in particular
I was looking at ancient Assyrian heart and ancient Egyptian art some of that is reflected
There's like a little border of flowers
Which comes from a Syrian art?
Yeah, those are the main things
Cutout style and the Syrian stuff and you know you you made this land is mine
did you have the
Sadomasochism film in mind or did that emerge afterwards? No
I knew I knew I wanted to make this film about Passover and that's why I watched Exodus and that's how
Sadomasochism. I mean that's how this land is mine came to be
So I I just knew I wanted to do a film about Passover
I didn't know what it was gonna be because I had never read the Old Testament before and
Reading Exodus was of course an eye-opener
And the film I don't I didn't imagine what the film was gonna be
like when I started it other than the
Topic I would work around but the way the film is actually shaping up is a surprise to me
So we should probably walk everyone who's listening through the film itself. So you've created a variety of
What appear at least to be at the moment to be animated shorts that detail out different episodes in in the biblical narrative surrounding?
essentially surrounding Moses there's more to it than that, but certainly surrounding Moses and so yeah does the film
Does the film essentially concentrate
Solely on Exodus are there other elements of Old Testament stories that are you that you're including?
It's really just Exodus but also, you know Leviticus and Deuteronomy
and numbers all
have bits of Exodus
Right, right. So it's basically the story of Moses. It's a story of Moses, right? It's the story of the Exodus and then the
establishment of the
You know the tabernacle and the priesthood and the religion, right?
That's sort of the I mean, it's regarded as the birth of the Jewish people, right?
Right. And so now you said that when you were growing up you observed Passover, but not much else
yeah, so but you're
It's not unreasonable. I think to observe that there appears to be something like a deep religious sensibility in your in your work
I mean you seem to be treating the stories with a tremendous amount of respect. And so
What what do you what do you think's welling up from inside of you to do that?
well, I'm glad you recognized the risk the respect any respect for this was like I
Approached these stories with an open mind and an open heart and was expecting to find some wisdom in them
When I began this project I
Thought I'm going to explore the religion of my father. My father came from a religious Jewish family
But he wasn't really religious
when I was growing up, although he had
He he wanted us to observe Passover
I guess as part of our he want us to have some Jewish identity. He wanted us to be in touch with our heritage as
Jews
But it was a bit muddled
Like we we were forbidden from
Observing any Christian holidays, there was no Christmas in our house. Whereas a lot of secular Jews do observe Christmas
There was like a really half-assed Hanukkah and there were no other high. Holy days, and my dad was an atheist. So
After
spending years
reading
as many different versions of
Exodus and
Commentary on it and things relating to it and trying to understand it and trying to find some way to connect to it
What happened was I realized that I had found the religion of my father and that was a theism
So I I became sort of a born-again a theist
Reading this stuff. My my neutrality towards the religion changed to a kind of
abhorrence
towards it
Which is which is not to take away from
Its importance, you know, it's a cultural foundation right? Like I live in Western culture and
these texts are stories that everybody knows to some extent and
You know, they're very important and I respect them for that reason that they're like a cultural touchstone for everyone, but I did not
emerge from
exodus
Was you know, I had like less connection to God than I had ever had in my life
I actually had like a spiritual crisis like
you know, it was really hard for me to have any kind of sense of a Power greater than myself after reading this and
And working with it
And that's also being the case as a consequence of doing the animation
Yeah, because you know animation is like a meditation when you made an old story
It's just a long drawn-out meditation on it and sometimes insights can pop up while you're working on it
I mean, it's just like in your face every day. I mean I have a
there are insights that I have one of them a lot of them are comparative religion insights because the previous film was Sita sings the
blues'
so in this film I included Aran a lot and Sita sings the blues' I left out, Lakshmana who is
roms brother and
I decided not to do that here
Even though with a lot of these stories when they're turned into films
Aran is made into this minor character and a lot of things that Aaron does in movies. They show Moses doing them like casting the
Staff down and it turns into a snake that was that was Aaron's business
But anyway, I showed Aaron in this and I thought about how both stories have these brothers
Have like the big important memorable brother and the other brother who?
Actually carries out quite a bit of the work
That's a similarity and of course both stories also have a
Really gruesome scene after what? We normally think of as the end like with Exodus especially growing up with Passover
I'd always thought a story was, you know, the Hebrews were slaves and then
You know
They were free. Right like the end is they're free. They crossed the Red Sea to get away from the Egyptians hooray
And of course what actually happens in the story after that is there's this Hebrew on Hebrew slaughter
Because of the golden calf and a whole bunch of those Hebrews who were liberated they die
Yeah, well liberation turns out to be a very complicated thing
Yeah, you know, it's funny when I when I watched the Americans go into Iraq
know with her initial optimism and
Then the absolute disintegration of the Iraqi state
I thought well and then the failure to produce something, you know stable as a consequence
I thought well a little bit of Exodus would have gone a long ways
It was quite funny in some sense because in a black way
because of course the people who
invaded Iraq who planned the invasion or
Were at least nominally
Committed Christians and I thought well
they took out the tyrant like
Just as the Hebrews escaped from the tyrant
let's say but no Exodus lays it out pretty clearly as you escaped from tyranny into the desert and
That's no joke and it's 40 years, right? It's three generations before the desert disappears and in the desert there's
nothing, but inter inter tribal warfare and
mmm D and the conflict
around new emerging values which is of course the conflict between the
idolization of the golden calf and and
the necessity for the new rules that Moses imposes
It's no picnic and then made a lot of the Old Testament is like that even I'd be doing a series of lectures
I don't know if you know about this, but I've done 12 lectures on the old
I've actually become quite popular. I think the first one has about three quarters of a million views and
I've been attempting to treat the stories with as much respect as I can because like you I believe that they're their
foundational stories and
um, I would say that my respect for them has actually grown and
my
relationship with whatever you might regard as transcendent has been improved by that but
Be that as it may
Even in the story of Abraham, you know, he's called forward by God to go out into the world
He's an old man by that time right? He's 75 years old
He should have left his family his father's house and and his
kinsmen long before but God calls him on an adventure to go out into the land of the stranger and to leave his home and
You know, it just goes terribly badly for Abraham
I mean the first thing he encounters is a
Famine and then he moves into the tyranny of Egypt and then you know the Pharaoh takes his wife. So it's
One of the things that you can say about the Old Testament is that it's not naively optimistic in any sense of the word
But the Passover story
kind of is as its as people observe it like when you read the Passover story, it's just this nice part and
That like I say that other part that later chapter, we never discussed that it Passover
Anyway, and you know, the closest we'll come is 40 years in the desert
Like I did know that the Jews wandered the desert for 40 years. I didn't know they killed each other
Right and and this is something similar to the Ramayana
Because the Ramayana is frequently told without the last chapter without the ohter. Akanda, which is the difficult part, right?
Which I think is the richest and most interesting part of the whole story
So I focused on it and see if this thing's the blues
but but yeah, I mean, I think that what
The most valuable parts of these stories are the most
Difficult and they're the parts that are left out and most people don't know about you have to actually read them. Yeah
well, they are the most useful parts because life is full of difficulty and
so with you over if you
Leap over the parts of the stories that are pessimistic and dark then
You missed part of what the stories are trying to teach you about how to prepare for catastrophe
I mean it says obviously in the Exodus story
the fact that the Hebrews escaped from tyranny is presented as a good thing and even as something that God wills
but it's by no means a straightforward passage from
Tyranny to the promised land. I mean and Moses doesn't make it to the promised land right? He he dies before he gets there
Yeah, and even the promised land
Is not nearly as much fun as it spin
As we have been led to believe
Right, like they're they're constantly the Jews are constantly falling short right there constantly angering God
They're never getting their shit together. You know God just keeps
You know God's ambivalence towards them
persists ya
Think that's very realistic because there are very few times in life where even if you're not
suffering from the tyranny of other people or or
Yourself that it's very difficult to walk the proper straight and narrow path and to keep everything organized and to keep things going properly
I mean, there's no there's never any shortage of severe challenges
Yeah, so enough, even if you're chosen by God, let's say there's no shortage of severe challenges
You also see that in all the other stories in the Old Testament. I mean, um
Even when God is walking with someone say like Abraham or Noah for that matter
It's pretty still pretty much non-stop carnage. Chubby. Noah. Noah has his family together and
His generations are perfect. Right and he walks with God, so he's properly oriented in the world, but he still has to
build the ark and and get through the damn storm and and
And and be humiliated by his children at the end and it's it's it's a very rough business
so in the in one of your
Shorts, and I don't know the name of it. It's the one
Where thee I guess it's the one that specifically deals with the Passover where the Egyptian firstborns are all killed. Yeah. Yeah
What's that one called death of the firstborn Egyptians? Terrible we go an appropriate title. I
Can't help but Harbor the suspicion that you had a fair bit of sympathy for the Egyptians
Yeah, well, you know
They had some great art
Yes. Yeah, and you do a wonderful job by the way of incorporating that into that film
It's that one is spectacularly beautiful. Well, thank you and they had religion and
I
Mean so doing visual research for this project
There's not a lot of really great ancient Hebrew art
possibly or probably because
It's against the religion to make art. You're not supposed to make graven images. So
in terms of coming up with a style that evoked this I had to
Yeah, I was looking at art from the region and I was like, oh, it's all Egyptian and Assyrian
those are the ones those are the people there that made the
Art fantastic art it breaks my heart that
That's supposed to be evil
Right that that that art which actually moves me when I look at it is what we're supposed to smash, right?
Like that's that's what we're commanded to destroy because it's it's all full of idols
I am NOT down with that. So I
You know just naturally was gonna sympathize with the Egyptians. This is all here. Well, there's a Roger there's a real
tension there that I think is worth thinking about you know, because I
Understand why from a psychological perspective. I understand why there was an injunction against making images and you know,
You see the same thing happened out right now with Isis say in the Middle East where they're destroying world
For example all the great Buddhist art and all those ancient
Monuments which of course is an absolute and utter catastrophe
but
Legend I mean they're following it better than we do
Right, right
well
So so the conundrum seems to me to be that
And this has also played out in the story of Exodus with the golden calf
But you know
the the idea of God is supposed to be something at least in principle that you can't really grip that you can't really
Encapsulate, you know that you can't dogmatically represent because then it turns into an idol and an idol and ideology are very much the same
Thing and I think ideology is terribly dangerous, you know
Because you take something
Concrete like an axiom of some sort you you you that's very concrete and then you make that your highest value and it narrows you
and then restricts you and also makes you incredibly dangerous and so
The idea that there's a great danger in idolization I think is uh is a very very powerful notion
And so I think that's what informed the restrictions against making
graven images of God because you end up confusing the image with the
Transcendent reality right and then you think that you understand it and you have it in your hands
but it certainly does seem to have some pretty
dramatically negative consequences when the consequence of that is the absence of
visual art in any profound sense and also this injunction to destroy
No
the idols of well of the foreigner or or of the hair of the person whose heretic older or and
I'm not exactly sure. How do
What would you say?
I'm not exactly sure what the mediating path is between those two extremes and I think a real artist and
I definitely think that you
belong in that category
as someone who isn't using
idols as representation because you're using your artistic talent to push beyond what you already know like it's a form of
exploration rather than a form of
Canonization or or categorization, right?
it's it's uh, it's uh,
it's a journey into the unknown and an extension of the way that people think and I think of that as a
Way of uniting with the transcendent rather than trying to encapsulate it in some sort of formulate box
But there is a great danger of that kind of formula formulas ation. So
Anyways, there is that danger and that's that is of course the commonest
Interpretation of the injunction against idols, but I think that
I mean, it's it's never born out right? It's like any injunction against that kind of
Idolatry has never resulted in the absence of idolatry ever
And we can clearly do it with abstract concepts. We can clearly do it you me clearly don't need images to do this
So you could argue that you could do it with words just as effectively, you know anything
And
So it doesn't work I wondered while I was working on the film
Whether it might have been a simple and misunderstood injunction against using Egyptian
Hieroglyphics and that it was a requirement to use Semitic written language
Rather than Egyptian because Egyptian hieroglyphics are full of things that fly in the air and things that crawl on
The ground and things that swim in the sea and and men and women all that stuff because I was working on these little animated
hieroglyphs I was like, maybe it was just this which would have made that's right because
Because they are
Egyptian when when these stories were written down and they were promoting the Semitic language. That's what you were supposed to use
In some sense in the same categories the dietary prescriptions, right?
Because the best evidence for the reason for those dietary prescriptions isn't hygiene or anything like that
It's don't eat the food that your that the people who worship other gods eat, right? Yeah. There's a variety of
Useful reasons for that and certainly one of them. Is that it? Yep, you know
well, it's a price and an advantage is that the people you eat with are your kinsmen and your tribesmen pretty much by definition and
So if you share a pallet if you if you share a menu and there are and you share restrictions
It's much easier for you to socialize with the people who have the same restrictions that you do
So it seems to be a reasonably intelligent way of keeping a culture cohesive them moment
certainly
It certainly worked for a very long period of time and so that that would be an idea that's in keeping with that
Isn't it you certainly don't use the idle?
Representations of the people who you are not because then you integrate with them and your and your culture disappears
And you don't use their language and you don't use you don't write down things that they can read
Right, but so much of these
The books of Moses were about be different from your neighbors
Like don't let your neighbors corrupt you you are different from your neighbors and interestingly
I was raised with that right like my father the AC atheist Jew
was adamant about
You know
Not doing the Christmas things when I went to school
You know, they would have Christmas projects in the winter and he would say just tell your teacher
You don't have to do this project cause you're Jewish. He never said you don't have to do the project because you're an atheist
Just because you're Jewish, right?
And so we maintain some sort of difference in spite of not actually practicing
Jewish religion really? Yeah
Well, it's one of the things that's always been interesting interesting to me about Judaism particularly and a mystery
I would say and you know, I think there are very many ways of believing in God and
one way of believing is
conscious and
that would be the sort of belief that you can state as I believe or I don't believe and
I think in some sense that's the weakest form of belief and it's also the one that's most easily undermined
I think the more profound forms of belief are ones that you act out
There like a dance in some sense and they're built into your behavioral coding and and they're not so easily
Criticized and undermined because they don't really operate at an intellectual level
No, like like for example watching your videos
It's not they're not reducible to an intellectual exercise
You know, I can't watch them
and and first of all
I can't say exactly what it is that you're up to
And even if I could lay out a reasonably comprehensive description of what you're up to which would be by no means complete
it wouldn't be easy for me to mount an intellectual attack on that because
because of your use use of in some sense with the cutouts and your use of
Imagery and your use of music it it puts the entire discussion on a plane that can't be easily
Reducible to an intellectual discussion and so in Judaism you see this and and this is the case I think with the atheist Jews
perhaps most
self-evidently is that the rituals are kept and the division is kept and the encoded actions are kept and
the person might say well
I don't believe in God and the proper objection to that might be something like well
You might say that you don't believe in God, but you sure act it out
Well, it seems to me that you know people have asked me about my religious faith
which is a question that I find quite intrusive and
Not know not that people don't have the right to ask it because they certainly do but I mean, I'm I'm sufficiently
ignorant about my own orientations in some sense to not know exactly how to answer that but one answer that I find quite
useful and I think fairly truthful is that I certainly act as if there's a god and
Undead the rest of it I leave I suppose in some sense in a cloud of
As of yet
Incomplete ly explored ignorance because I do believe that human beings have a relationship with the transcendent now
I see that manifest itself in in great art for example where people seem to be able to reach beyond themselves to produce something
That's of spectacular
lasting intense emotional and practical significance
So that's the realm of the inspiration, you know, and I don't think that we understand that very well at all
And I don't think that we understand consciousness very well as well at all
in fact, and I think it is a fundamental element of being
so
but but it is interesting in it and in your in your work to like I see and
It's interesting to hear you. Talk about it. I see a profound religious. What would you call it?
Well, I see a profound religious spirit at work and it's so interesting to me that that your experience of reading Exodus and also
Doing these animations has actually for you being a an increased sense of divorce from the from let's say the realities of the text
Yeah, but you know
That I so the word I used to describe it is I was bereft
After spending all this time with them because the more time I spent with the test the more time I spent working on this the
Just the other less connected to anything I would call God I
felt and
after I finished those scenes it took me a really long time to
Get inspiration for finishing the film I
guess I finished the last scene of the
Moses parts a year and a half ago and
I just could not continue work on the film because I was thinking like more Moses more
Old Testament and it just made me feel sick
Every time I approached it well
Is it possible just out of curiosity that that was a form of something like spiritual exhaustion?
Because I mean your films are very very serious and there and there and they're very complex
and so I kind of wonder too if you just haven't like drained yourself of of
Inspiration as a consequence of working on this day long
I mean, they're very complex deep themes
And I know as you said they do sit at the bottom of the culture and it's no
Joke to mess around with that kind of thing. That's that's true. But I now see what I was missing. I mean I've I've
My muse has returned
So I you know
I could say that I'm not religious, but I clearly
practiced like a religious person because I have a mousse and I'm inspired by my muse and I have faith in my muse and I
even have prayer that I say to my muse, so
that's
you know, that's that's a sort of religious lifestyle or
Spiritual one anyway, yes. Well you okay and you so you said that you even pray too? Yeah
Tell me tell me about the muse. Okay, what would you like to hear my muse prayer?
Amusing okay our idea which art in the either that cannot be named
By vision come thy will be done on earth as it is an abstraction
Give us this day our daily spark and forgive us our criticisms as we forgive those who critique against us and lead
Us not into stagnation
But deliver us from evil for thine is the vision the power and the glory forever. Amen
hmm
So that certainty seems to me to be a like I would think of that as a as a
Mantra to open up the gateway between you and this transcendent force that allows people religious inspirations
I mean and you're doing something like clearing out your ego and
And I think it is very interesting that it's associated with the with the the Lord's Prayer
especially with regards to you know, you make this interesting identity between
Criticism and temptation, you know and one of the things of course that does intuition leave us not to stagnation. Yes
Yes, but deliver us from criticism. I think you got didn't you?
yes, I don't to stagnation but deliver us wait wait, but deliver us from Ito oh
Boy, I would forgive us our criticisms as we forgive those who critique. Yes. Yes
That's a very interesting element of it too because
it's often the case one of the things that I
Teach my students when they're writing is to get that critical spirit the hell out of the way to begin with
No, because what people try to do is produce and edit at the same time
Yeah, and you actually cannot do that
What you have to do is open yourself up to thee to thee to to the creative process and all of its errors
Because when you first start it's going to be very much error written, but you have to allow yourself to
manifest that error ridden spark of creativity to begin with and keep the criticism at
bay and also the ego element I think is extremely interesting because to
The degree that you're trying to bend your artistic production to the proximal demands of your ego
Then you actually you pollute it you you propaganda is it yeah you reduce it
I would to something like an idol because it then it heavy then it's to serve some other master rather than
Whatever it is that is supposed to be in some sense flowing through you
told
Total and that serve the other master, that's a good way to put it. I have a real problem doing work for money
I love money
And what I like to do is do my work and then encourage people to send me money
But the whole this whole thing where somebody says I'll give you this money if you do the work I've done that
it's just called being a professional artist and
It never works out for me. I mean it I did this
segment of this commercial film
Ironically it was Khalil Gibran's the Prophet
All animated and I did it for money I got paid
Well, I thought I was never gonna animate again after that cuz it burned me out so badly
it was a really unpleasant process because
The authority in this was not my muse. The authority was the people with the money really
The money you were subjugating the greater to the lesser. Yeah, and if I do that even a little bit it
It's the feeling is horrible and I can I liken it to how I imagined
Prostitution like all the warnings about prostitution and what it what it does to your soul. Even if you think it's hunky-dory
I I can relate to that when I
Do the work for money. It's really different. Yeah than what I'm doing. Okay, so, it's your prayer
so
Now you modified the Lord's Prayer. Yeah, and so did you write that down?
Like how how in the world did you come up with this and thank you for actually telling me I'm quite amazed that you did
Because of course it's a peculiar thing and I mean that in the best possible sense
Yeah, but it seems also to be quite a private thing
Out about it since I mean the thing with Sita sings the blues' is it was like such a profoundly weird experience
Making that film and it was so much like the channeling and it was so much just getting out of my own way
That I did want to share that I mean cuz people would ask me these questions
So how did you make that looks like I don't I don't really know
Phone you said you got out of your own way
Yeah
You know and one of the things that then that I've been struck by with regards to both the prophetic tradition in the Old Testament
And also the the passion story in the New Testament is that there's a tremendous emphasis in those stories
On getting out of your own way
You know because the idea is supposed to be a this is part of the idea of the dying and resurrecting hero
of course is that you're supposed to left everything in you that gets in your way burn away and die so that
Whatever can flow through you that has true value and that's oriented to the words the highest good
Let's say which I think is what you're doing when you're establishing
Relationship with your muse is that there isn't anything that's part of the ego part of the critical capacity
that's that's inappropriate or part of let's say worldly concerns that's interfering with your ability to reach beyond yourself and
That's that's a holy calling. I would say it's and maybe it's the primary holy calling
I think I certainly think it is but it seems to me to be the case and I do think in some sense
That's what artists act out when they're really being artists because they're they're establishing a relationship with the source of inspiration
Whatever that is and it's not like we understand that we don't understand that. It's something that's very very deep
Yeah, I do feel or I do believe if I have beliefs. I do believe that
Regarding it as something that comes from elsewhere something bigger than yourself is for me helpful
I don't I don't like this idea that it's all me
I I'm connected to other people and connected through culture and through language which is culture and through art which is culture
I mean, I'm just like a fish swimming in a sea of culture, right and
What we call creating is really, you know, absorbing and and processing all of this
Culture that I'm a part of and just expressing a little bit out
I'm very dubious of the idea of originality. For example, I wrote an essay about that the cult of originality. I think that's
Delusional yeah. Well maybe the cult part of the originality idea is that it's
That it's tied up with ego
Yeah, because I think that people can be spectacularly original, but I don't know if you get to attribute that to their ego
you know to that part of them that you call me and the mind is a very strange place because
There's obviously a part of it that we are
That we identify with as ourselves
That would be the me that would be the ego and it's obviously it and it's the thing. I think that is capable of generating
Egotistical criticisms and and standing on principles for self defense or for dominance display or something like that
That's you know, it's sort of a it
Operates at a relatively low level of moral virtue, but then there's parts of us that are obviously far beyond ourselves, you know
And that's the part for example that generates dreams and visions and perhaps even ideas
Because why one of the things I really liked about reading Carl Jung?
one of the things he made me really conscious of was the effect that
Anna nietzsche, of course talked about this in the same way to some degree is that it's not so much that you have ideas
It's that one you could say. No, no, no, don't be so sure about that the ideas have you?
Oh, yeah, so there's that and then the next thing is well, it isn't so much that you think up the ideas
It's that you encounter them
if you open yourself up to the possibility of encountering them and it is like a process of discovery rather than a process of
Origination, let's say yeah, and that's also so you could say even if you're like a biological
materialist which I actually don't think you can be because
Biological materialism doesn't help us account for consciousness in the least so far. We don't have a good theory of consciousness
You're saying like a biological materialist theory of consciousness cuz I'm a biological materialist. I mean, I think biology exists
Well, yes, right like scholars. I just don't I just don't think that it provides
it isn't sophisticated enough to provide answers to some of the most fundamental questions about human existence like
Conscience right now, I agree about and you know the idea that you just expressed that when you're in a creative
When you're engaging in the creative process with whatever it is that you're praying to let's say that you're opening yourself up to something
That's beyond you
Now you could say that that comes from deep within the human psyche which is a psychoanalytic way of thinking about it
And and I think a reasonably appropriate way of thinking about it
But I don't think it's any more
Reasonable in some sense than making me than generating the hypothesis that you're opening yourself up to
Unknown forces in the cosmos because I think that's justice
It's just as intelligent and account for the phenomena as the beste as the former one
We now are in
contact with things that are beyond us and I do think that that's that's a large part of what the artist actually demonstrates and
And keeps it and keeps in front of people. I think beauty in particular is a powerful force for that
And and that's I mean when I've watched your videos really them, they're so beautiful that they virtually bring me to tears
Oh, especially in combination with the music because I'm very sensitive to music, but you have this unbelievable
capacity for for grace and for color and for and for deep respect for the music which I think is also
Really quite remarkable like you're you know, I often see
Movies that use good music but that don't have much respect for the music they'll they'll cut it
You know in the middle of a phrase or something like that. I remember the movie Magnolia was a real exception to that
that that movie uses music beautifully and
Woody Allen is very good at using music beautifully and so is who is the director of The Shining?
Kimber Kubrick elbrick. Hey, I mean he loves music and
His work
Clockwork orange' has some of the same kind of perverse Beauty that some of your animation has, you know,
Does he he is those great?
Beethoven pieces that were that were transformed into other droning music by Walter Wendy
Carlos and and set these brutal scenes have mayhem to beautiful music
Which was also I think a very profound thing to do it Connor
I mean
of course Germany is the home of Nazism and it's also the home of
Beethoven and Bach and so you really can't separate those things in some sense and so
Okay, so let's go to the copyright issue to some degree now
Now you're you're not a fan of the idea of copyright. And and that's that's interesting to me because it has been arguably a
reasonably
Efficient way for people to let's say protect theft of their protect themselves from the theft of their intellectual property
Although I would say that's broken down quite badly now for people like musicians
Because their their work is so distributable. Are you against copyright for all forms of intellectual property or
Why don't you tell us a little bit about your your ideas? Well, you say that as if intellectual property exists
What is intellectual property?
Well, I guess to some degree I'll take the easy way out and say that's a legal issue
But I would you know, I would say that at least to some degree intellectual property it's the consequence of of
abstract work
Now when you because it's certainly possible to work abstractly
constructing something like you're constructing your movies or perhaps a book and
It seems to me that it's not unreasonable to propose that that deserves some of the same ownership
protection that a physical entity would like a
I'm not I'm not sure that there's
There there's some level of similarity between you owning your house and not allowing other people in and you owning
The more abstract work that you've done, but I'm not and I'm certainly not
Attempting to engage you in an argument about the benefits of copyright. I presume that you have a very well thought-through
Stance on this and and well it begins with it begins with acknowledging that culture is not property
It just didn't and what we were just talking about a few minutes ago. Where where does this stuff come from?
You know, it comes from something bigger than ourselves. We were just talking about, you know, we do know actually originated this we certainly work
But I didn't originate any of the work that I'm putting out there. I mean I just stated it
But we don't own children either, you know
We let our children go out into the world if you if you want to own your child for
96 years and you know control everything
well, then that's
You get a dead child basically you get a crippled
you know non human being and the thing with cultural works is they
Like I say I'm a fish swimming in there, you know, it's like water what happens when you enclose water. It becomes stagnant
It becomes nasty it becomes toxic
As to you know, I know that for my own work
It has to go out in the world and it has to continue circulating and for me personally
copyright interferes with that because you put a monopoly around something if I it's one person or even
If I am licensed my copyrights to others when when it's centrally controlled
It does not move and I did a lot of experiments the Sita sings the blues' and by far
The best way to get it into the world is to just let people carry it into the world, right?
They have that's certainly what I've experienced as well, you know
And and people are also taking my lectures and cutting them into pieces
Which is not something I expected and then putting up pieces of different lengths on on
on the on the net and I've had companies contact me and say
You know for uh for a fee will more or less hunt these people down and enforce your copyright
and I thought well no one I'm I'm more thinking about message in a bottle approach to this and I'm willing to let go where
where it
To let the wind blow where it wants to blow
Let's say he could put it that way
and also you you're making more money that way because as you just pointed out
People are sending people want to support you. They want to support you because they actually see your work
Right, if you were taking down all these all these instances of your work getting seen because of copyright fewer people would see your work
The audience is the most efficient distribution machine that exists. That's yes
Definitely being a case for me and I'm a fortunate too because I've been involved in some political controversy over the last year
some people that I know
Who who?
Who have been involved in say let's say broadly similar political controversies have been demonetized on YouTube
You know
and I'm outside of that because everything I put up is free and people are terrifically willing to
support me but I mean
It's also very fortunate and a new thing that this these new platforms for direct support of creative people
Let's say have just emerged and developed which is you know
Thank thank God for that because it's very difficult for creative people to monetize their production. Yep. So so now all right, so
Just to say something about more on this
With my films going out for free the benefit to me. Is that far more people see them that way?
Than would see them if I were trying to control them and trying to be people to pay me to see the things
So I made more money
Releasing Sita sings the blues' for free than I ever had before in my career
Where everything was copyrighted the consequence of all my comic strips being copyrighted is that people just don't see them
So, yeah, so just like releasing it is good, but the other asset so that that's the benefit to me
The benefit to society is that you overcome
Like a form of societal brain damage when you ignore copyright and I gave a talk called copyright is brain damage
You can look that up. But if you if you look at all of us are neurons in a great mind
And all of us transmit and receive information
Copyright blocks that function or in an attempt to control that function. I mean, of course, you can't you can't have a brain with
Totally uncontrolled, you know firing of sine APS's that's that's madness
But I really think that each human being shares work that they love
so if you just let humans share work that they love and
you know, they naturally will not share work that they don't love then you end up with a really healthy system and
You know really good works are going to succeed in that system. Whereas
Controlling things with copyright is this artificial?
Damage to that system. Well, there's also been a fair bit of crookedly in relationship to that in recent years
And I would say perhaps Disney is more responsible for that than any other organization, you know
And so it was Disney that was instrumental in getting copyright extended from fifty to seventy-five years
and I really did think that that was a form of crime because some of those early Disney movies and
Category particularly are are incredibly culturally significant and to forestall
Proper discussion of those cultural artifacts I think is truly
Damaging and it was a travesty that that that copyright extension was granted over
Again, and Disney's not the only one I mean most of our cultural heritage is controlled by five big corporations
Almost everything now. I mean, everything is owned by someone and once it's owned
It can be sold to someone else and it all ends up in the hands of you know, Viacom and Sony
everything
So now with regards to copyright do you do you draw a distinction
What about patents and things like that? Do you think that they are technically different?
Now I have a problem with patents. Although my expertise is not in the area of patents. So the one
Legal concept that is classified as intellectual property
Which is a misnomer that is not completely fundamentally bankrupt is trademark
because trademark
Theoretically has something to do with fraud and you know, you need you don't need but people desire some mechanism to to
Control or punish fraud so
Trademark alone would be that it's not usually used that way
It's usually abused as as much as anything under the intellectual property label
But at least it has some you could make some excuse for it to exist
Right, right. So yeah
Well, I mean part of it, I guess part of the claim for the protection of originality
We might say is also the protection you could argue for for the Virginia witness, you know
Like I might want to know that and maybe legal protection can help with this that I might want to know that
The thing that I'm watching or the thing that I'm consuming is actually produced by the person who said that they produced it
So if I go on your website and I watch a Tina Paley animated short
I want to make sure that it isn't something someone copying you and using your identity as as as a form
Well, it's a it's a form of parasitism essentially so
Yeah, I mean, but the thing is I don't have a lot of need for that largely because I do free my work
So most people are aware of something. That's by me is by me
Then you know there's I guess some danger or the way I might invoke
Trademark law is if somebody
Edited something of mine everyone's welcome to edit and redistribute it. But if they said that the Edit and redistribution was mine
It was like no, you know like like the work I did is mine
But you have to take responsibility for that edit and redistribution. I'm not responsible for your edit and redistribution
So if they add some message to it, that is not mine
I don't want that attributed to me and I suppose I could invoke
Trademark or something to do that? I don't know folks something but really actually do is just go and say hey I never said that
Yes. Well, that's a lot simpler than engaging in legal battles. We're roughly the equivalent of a fairly serious disease. Yes
I took a legal vow of non-violence
I just don't want that system
Yeah, well
It's certainly a way of keeping your life simpler it unless you know, unless you get attacked by something. That's truly malevolent
And of course that can happen from time to time. Okay. So let's go back to Seder masochism
So it's gonna come out in
2018 and
I'm very much looking forward to that
Yes couple of things is um
You know, it's it's so interesting because when I watch your your shorts I
I
Remember a couple of them that have Moses
Wandering through the desert with the pillar of light leading him on, you know cloud pillar. Yes. That's right the cloud
Yes
and and you've animated that very interesting way and it's going to kind of
Randhir as well which which again spoke to me of something approximating a profound religious sensibility, which is partly why it was
Surprised by your comments about let's say the intellectual effect of your endeavours on your on your relationship with belief
But you're just talking to my ego
This this is that you go to ego talk
Well, you know, I think now and then we managed to make it amused amuse talk. Well, maybe a little bit but
You're gonna hear from my ego. Yes. Yes. Yes. Well that's always the danger in talking to artists
Yeah, right because I think generally when you speak with artists you speak to the inferior part of them
Not because their ego is inferior compared to the ego of other people
But because the part of them that you would like to communicate with is actually the part that's generating the art
Right so already doing it's communication exactly. That's why I would rather I mean in general
It's like I speak better through my art than any other or it's men
That's not even I any more right it's but whatever my yes mystic expressions
Talking head. Yes. Yes. Absolutely. Absolutely
and I mean part of the reason I
wanted to do the interview though was to find out what your ego thinks of all of this as well as to take the
Opportunity hopefully to bring your work to to perhaps to some people who don't know about it yet and okay
So now you're making this magnificent
Production about Exodus and about the Old Testament and that's a pretty strange thing to do. Let's say the modern world
What do you have any sense of what you're hoping that will accomplish
I know I know that you want to launch it and see what happens and that there's curiosity associated with that. But but
do you have do you have a
hypothesis or a theory about
What it is that this is doing in the broader sense how you're contributing to the cultural conversation. I?
I'm sure that I do I can't access those thoughts right now
But I'll learn a lot more once it once it goes out. All right. Well focus it. Okay, you know in the
Pinnochio movie of course thickness is a very ancient theme in order for
The puppet the marionette whose strings are being pulled by forces beyond his control in order for him to become real
There's a variety of things he has to do he has to learn to tell the truth and he has to learn not to be
An erotic victim and he has to learn not to be an impulsive
pleasure-seeking
Victim of totalitarian processes all of those things, but then he has to go down to the bottom of chaos itself and rescue his father
Now I can't help but think that that's part of what you're doing. I mean, you said it yourself in the interview, right?
because
you said that you were attempting to make some connection with the belief of your father and to make some sense out of it and
So you are in fact going into the void? Let's say to
Rescue your father from the belly of the whale
and and you know, it seems to me that we're in a period of of
chaotic instability in our culture that it actually has a fair bit of danger associated with it and that I
felt a strong impulse to go back to these original stories to find out what they are and
And to establish them to re-establish them
Let's say as foundation or whatever that might mean and it might be my imagination but it seems to me that that that's associated
That that's akin in some sense to what you're doing with Exodus
Well, yes, and when I set out I did set out to connect to my father rescue my father
But what I have learned in the past year is that actually I'm looking for my mother and
I think I found her
Okay. Well, no. No, obviously I'm going to have to ask you to elaborate on that
I should know if I can in words, right? Like I'm still in the process of doing this but it's like
it's like I have been seeking to connect with this this father this God the Father and
Also my own father, which I didn't have the best connection with nothing, you know
nothing
really terrible or anything just never really connected with him and I
I'm wrong for that right like a lot of my life because the culture tells me that
that's really important, you know like and
all the all the
Psychologists say you know, there's you know, really important thing. So my whole life it's been like oh, you know,
Maybe I wouldn't be messed up about this or that thing. Maybe this is a daddy issue
You know
I gotta get right with my dad even though he's dead and I'm just like looking and looking there and it's like
Wait, I I missed something
Right, like it's my mother. It's it not it's all of our mothers and you talked about the original stories
You referred to the Old Testament text in the original stories. Well, they're not you know, we have
Most of the history of human religion was not these stories as far as
As far as I have read or learned the early human conception of the divine was female
everywhere and
we have broken a connection to that and actually the story of Exodus to me what it is is it's the the solidifying of the
That change that it was a long
gradual
Process of moving from goddess to gods and goddesses to just God just one God
But I'm reaching further back and I realize, you know when I when I found that and when I started working with that
earlier
Religion when we have no text for it
All we have is some artifacts many artifacts from all over the world and beautiful symbols
And of course, there's that book by Eric Newman the Great Mother which talks about all the symbols. Yes. I was just
Yes, I read that sucker cover-to-cover that you read the origins. Have you read the origins and history of consciousness?
I hate my Newman I have not but I did
Yeah, I I'm with you I like look he writes like a lead weight
It was just good to immerse myself in that so that is what I was longing for and back to the old testament
Those things are in the old estimate
They're all portrayed as the other and the enemies and what we're trying to stop out, but they're in there. So
so in that way, I relate to the Old Testament not the heroes of the Old Testament Moses and Aaron and them I
I
take
Inspiration from the stiff-necked people
Now it's like oh there's stiff-necked people. They're disobedient like yes, that's great
You know
Those are the if there's if there's any history to this which there probably isn't but it's like those are the ones I'm descended from
the bad ones
Anyway, what was C. I don't know. It's interesting because
In the Pinocchio story and in the classic stories of of journeying to the belly of the whale or journeying into the underworld
It's often but not always males who are doing it and rescuing their father and it isn't obvious to me psychologically
What happens when a woman goes to the underworld to rescue her father?
It isn't clear what she's going to discover there, you know, and it seems to me that you're you're you know
You're using your creative pseudopods to sort of feel out that territory and discover what might be there
so and that seems very important too because obviously
there's there's a problem in our culture and the problem is how what is exactly then the relationship between
Femininity and women and these let's call them patriarchal religions. I
mean there's you know, one of one of use criticisms of
Christianity and of course this is also evident in Erik Norman's work is that there's there's a Trinity obviously in Christianity
Let's say and it's a fairly comprehensive all there's God the Father and that's tradition and there's the Holy Spirit and that's you might think
About that as the muse and there's God God in the son form
Which is you know him the human being who's who's vulnerable and mortal and who's destined to live on earth them that those are nice
elements of the divine but there's a missing fourth as far as Jung was concerned and he thought of that as sometimes
constituted by the figure of Satan so that was where evil said it, but also sometimes call instituted by
femininity itself and that those two things were often conflated as well because they were the other and
And that isn't a complicated technical problem because it's not obvious
It's not precisely obvious what the divine model is for women
Especially now that they have control over the reproductive function because there's sort of half women in the traditional classic
Biological sense half female but also in some sense half male
Control over the reproductive function sadly, I mean if we lived in that world we could we could talk that way
But it's now practically speaking women really don't
You mean because it's unreliable
Well for one thing are you talking about like?
hormonal pills birth control
Pills. Okay. Well, like I can't take them right like they you know
They have horrible side effects for me and quite a few women. Yes
So it's not like it's not like oh we invented this pill
I mean, that's actually one of the that's like a great example of you know
Our patriarchal society right like a pill like that could be developed for men men wouldn't tolerate the side-effects?
in fact
They were developing a pill like that for men and then they cut the experiments short because men weren't weren't tolerating the side effects
Which were members than the side effects for women?
But women are going to tolerate that shit because they're yes what price is much higher? Yeah. We're physically more vulnerable
Anyway, it never ends
although
This is why I believe in biological reality. By the way, this is what
biological material is because
Regardless of my identity regardless of my ideas, you know every month
I'm doubled over in pain and you know having like very real
consequences of right of my biology well and you you just did a short
about the great mother
I know, you know
I wondered if you had written ointments book when I saw that because I got others
To that if that is an absolutely great book. And as I said, I would recommend oranges history of consciousness
It's yep. I think it would help answer some of the questions that you were talking about today. I
Believe you. Yeah, so and you know
It was the book that you said he wished he would have written
which is a hell of a thing for someone like him to say because he was a remarkable genius and so
so so I guess that the the new
Film and what's it called? The one that features the Great Mother God mother. Yes, exactly
And so is that now that seems importantly related to this issue that you brought up about?
Rediscovering the connection with your mother by going - yeah
Probably my actual mother. I mean the mother, you know the great mother great
I live with my actual mother. She's great and everything, but we're on a
metaphorical
Yes
Yeah, and that that actually is the first scene of sadomasochism
So I did the last scene first and then it took years for me to figure out what the first scene is
Oh, so damn interesting. Yeah, so that's just like and there's gonna be no introduction and no explanation
it's just that's gonna set the stage for
The Exodus story. It's that that follow
well
Thank you for talking with me
Thank you for being with me. I think that I wish you the best of luck with your
Film and I hope that exactly what should happen with it will happen
Thank you
and I'm going to steal liberally from your films to illustrate this interview if you don't mind and I'll try to be very
respectful and careful with the editing
Excellent, but actually I wouldn't be copying not stealing. Oh, yes
Okay. Well, thank you very much. It was a pleasure talking with you. Thank you. Likewise. All right